la couche pas
vient alors je vous êtes schizo je ne
pourrais pas rester dans un film far as
in fine c'est à dire porter sur mes
épaules un film en tant que metteur en
scène est ce que vous êtes parano oui
oui oui mais pas trop
en fait je crois que je souffre de
toutes les pathologies boubacar bah vous
dites seulement oui alors est ce que
vous êtes maso est ce que vous êtes sado
non est ce que vous êtes seau d'eau à
est ce que vous êtes exhibo est ce que
vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes nympho non géronto
non ça dépend de l'âge cinquante deux
ans ces vieux 52 ans alors oui eh ben
voilà
hélène de fougerolles voilà et 54 c'est
pour la vie mais ça va dépendre
chauffoir un cadre non ça va hein
pourquoi pas beau c'est bien même s'il
en est qui attend là bas qui se dit
[ __ ] c'est pas mal quand même 52 54 à
toutes tes chances travel aulas
maintenant je le déteste ce type de jeu
vient alors quelques email avant de
continuer gens